you ever hear about sports cars
Honestly by not focusing on it for real
everybody that wants it too fast Cuts
corners and then it's over
fall in love with it too not say I'm
gonna take the stairs like no no I love
to take this like once you love the
process they can get you there it's over
perspective that's right now I have to
go to work I'm privileged to go to work
yes or thank God I got options if I
really hate this job do I have
the humility to take a little less to do
something I like so that I do love it so
that when I go home I don't play
video games and watch Netflix and listen
to music to escape my life when
I go home I can work on my side hustle
that eventually becomes my real life